[Music]
[Applause]
cedar mass clive davis what artist's
success surprised you the most the
artist except i would say the very first
one when i had that epiphany and
eyeshadow up i had a natural gift I
would say Chaplin you know one big bro
because she wasn't a looker no she I
read in the book that she wanted to seal
the deal by having sex with you and you
wisely said no you're very informed well
she also was a big drug she must have
stunk and she just didn't look like
someone you'd want to have sex with it
under any no but I took it as the
highest form of cops I was not happy
with the formal sterile corporate
signing if you wanted something well it
demands like there's something in
between it's called a handshake you know
okay Maria what do you think about the
visa program in which foreigners can
gain permanent residents by investing
five hundred thousand dollars in the
u.s. project that creates jobs oh
there's a pathway to citizenship for for
most immigrants just come up with five
hundred thousand dollars and you're in
and then you got extreme you know this
is this is the whole thing with the
immigration debate is what folks keep
saying well should we legalize them or
should we actually create a pathway to
citizenship short of creating a pathway
decision
folks living within our borders we're
gonna have two classes of set of folks
living with our boards Americans and
then people that work for Americans and
that's not who we are like we've already
we've already lived that history and we
need to have political courage in this
moment in time recognizing that this is
a civil rights moment where we can
actually bring become that big tent
where people come out of the shadows and
actually if they believe in in America
and it's their possibility here that
they can actually become Americans
through a pathway to sonship anything
short of that bill basically creates two
sets of citizens living within our
borders but that but that
right I mean then you should get in
under stupid I would fully agree that
there are two sets of citizenship there
are two Americas there's half of America
who lives very well in this half of
America who doesn't know where their
meal is coming from
and it's not just immigrants I mean that
it's it's it's it's not but but right
now folks what their folks are proposing
or wiping that's why I'm here at a free
taping perfect perfect date night for
Friday night hey this is a fun date
night this is a fun day night but I have
to but I'm sure with you you know that
the idea that people are proposing to
have legalization for these folks but
not a pathway to citizenship you're
creating a permanent underclass and by
creating a permanent underclass all of a
sudden you know you start opening up the
can of worms of whole thing's what
happens to those legal citizens there's
the legal residents all of a sudden if
they have children are they American
citizens do we have to repeal the 14th
amendment I mean the idea of having
folks are basically stateless within our
borders 11 million of them it's not just
wrong and immoral but it's also not good
for national security or for economy I
mean you go down the list I mean it's
against our DNA as Americans and
entrepreneurs by the way that program
you mentioned is next see it works
pretty well and it tracks a lot of
capital united states a lot of people
come in with $500,000 and that's their
that's our that's our guard that works
that works very well yeah it does that
has worked pretty well so we're selling
it right now selling we're selling our
citizens right but it's also dishonest
but it's this honest because we keep
trying to claim to the American people
to the rest of the world that we don't
need unskilled labor but we do need
unskilled labor and so we need to create
a need to create a type of immigration
reform that actually provides the high
school labor but also that creates a
path for the folks that are actually
like this F just everything to be for
sale I mean I really feel like the root
problem in this country is that
everything has to be for profit for
right look this is the problem with the
prisons
this is the problem with the healthcare
system the problem with our with the
healthcare reform is not too much
socialism it's too much capitalism still
I just I just read it you know we people
think we do way more tests than other
countries actually we don't do that much
more tests it's just that the tests we
do give to patients cost twice as large
a lot there's a piece of cotton gauze
could I have twenty eight dollars look
at a lot of countries right off of
what's done in the u.s. you know they
whether it's pharmaceuticals in the end
the drugs that they're paying you know
one-fifth one-tenth the price in other
rich countries in whether that makes
sense is questionable but on the
immigration issues look I think it's
exactly right that we ought to be
looking across a skill distribution we
need more we have a baby boom
it helps us if you fill in the baby boom
with actual workers whose pay is going
to support retirees but when we were in
the white house one of the states I
can't remember what state called and
said we're giving a guy entrepreneur of
the Year award
I think it was Ohio we're giving him
Entrepreneur of the Year award but he's
from India and his his visa is running
out and he's about to be deported can't
you put it off till after the ceremony
but the answer was no well the white
house get involved in any awesome
appointment this is why this is why
Republicans are moving on this issue
because actually the business community
really wants emigrate comprehensive
immigration reform the evangelical
community desperately wants it so these
are the two biggest constituencies the
Republican Party and I think that's why
you see a lot of Republicans like Marco
Rubio saying we need to do something we
need to do a quickly why is the
Evangelic of community one cuz they
think it's the right thing to do it's
because they're a case of no because
well yes but I drove it but it's also
their fastest-growing demographic so in
the room ah there
customer true that's the same problem
the Catholic Church has when they look
out in the pews it's all white hair
looks like a Broadway show not a my
Paris epic use of my Paris the to the
Evangel Eccles group's defense they've
actually fit they're filling up a lot of
the role of government in rural areas
where there aren't government services
for these immigrants so they're saying
they recognize that they in order for
other peers just want forget what
Marissa look people get caught in the
system immigrants particularly in jails
and prisons and they don't have the due
process rights that any American has and
it is horrific I mean my grandparents
came to this country from Ireland now
they couldn't pay half a million's no
johns could I wish and believing my name
from Ireland so I came from Ireland just
a potato
there's my legs a guess but the notion
of I've seen women go into prison and
there's no beginning or end to this
process it just goes on for months into
years and it's it's it's an American
it's it's it's an American and it costs
a lot of money yeah cuz along and that's
the problem because you actually bank
army this country this is one of the
main many things that and Medicare
nothing more American than money thank
you very much ladies and gentlemen I
appreciate you coming and helping us out
thank you
Real Time with Bill Maher side a 90/10
ask bill and his guests or questions
right after the show at HBO calm